[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو الى حكومته قررت اقامه
بلده جديده في غلاف غزه مضيفنا ان اقامه
البلده دليل اخر على قوه غلاف غزه وقوه
اسرائيل بحسب تعبيره وقال انه يفخر بتعزيز
الاستيطان في جميع انحاء البلاد واكد ان
الامر المهمه للرد على ما سماه الارهاب هو
تعزيز الاستيطان
وقد وصفت حركه حماس بناء مستوطنه قرب قطع
غزه بالخطوه التصعيديه وقالت ان استمرار
اسرائيل في سياستها الاستيطانيه لن يجلب
الامن للمستوطنين وان الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تتحمل وحدها مسؤوليه اسكان مستوطنين قرب
القطاع ووضعهم في دائره الخطر
دلت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه الحصار الذي
تفرضه سلطات الاحتلال على مدينه اريحا
لليوم الثامن على التوالي وطالبت بضغط
دولي وامريكي على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لرفع هذا الحصار عن مدينه اريحا
ثر رئيس الاوكراني وزير الدفاع من منصبه
وعينه وزيرا للصناعات الاستراتيجيه وعين
في منصب وزير الدفاع مدير الاستخبارات
اللواء كيرلو بودانوس
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه السابق اوليكس
كل الاسلحه التي طلبتها ولم يبقى سوى
الطائرات التي قال
تستقبلها ايضا واكد ان بلاده اخبرت
حلفائها الغربيين رسميا بانها لن تستخدم
الاسلحه التي تم تزويدها بها لمهاجمه
الاراضي الروسيه
السلطات المواليه لروسيا في مقاطعه
دونيتسكن 4 مدنيين قتلوا اربعه في قصف
اوكرانيا على مدينه دنيا واعلن مقر
التنسيق الروسي عن تخطيط السلطات
الاوكرانيه لتنفيذ اعمال الاستفزازيه على
نطاق واسع في مدينه كراما الاتهام موسكو
بالاستهداف المتعمد للمستشفيات
نقلت
الصينيه ضل فوق الاراضي الامريكيه ثلاثه
ايام قبل ان يثير قلقا للجنرالات لاطلاع
بعيدا ونقلت وكاله رايترز عن مسؤول في
المنطقه هو جزء من اسطول صيني يتجسس على
خمس قارات
وقد تواعدت الصين بالرد على اسقاط المنطاد
وقالت وزاره الخارجيه النبيجين تحتفظ
بحقها في الرد على واشنطن بالوسائل
اللازمه خلال المواقف المماثله وجدد
المتحدث باسم الوزاره رفض بيجين للاجراء
الامريكي مشيرا الى ان المنطاد مدني انحرف
عن مساره بسبب ما سماها قوه قاهره
اشكركم على متابعه الموجه زي ما كنتم
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]